he is the pride of Piscataway New Jersey
now 11 seasons in the National Football
League Walter Payton Man of the Year
nominee for his team the Philadelphia
Eagles and I will introduce you Malcolm
Jenkins the same way I introduced you on
NFL Network the other day the only
person on planet earth to have two Super
Bowl rings beating Tom Brady and Peyton
Manning Malcolm Jenkins you did not know
that fact I appreciate you teaching that
you know to me about myself now that's
how I walk into every room ever ever
Brady obviously couple years ago and
then Manning 10 years ago in Miami yeah
how was it was that your rookie year Sal
had to be 21 what was that like walking
into that Stadium that night I mean it
was crazy I mean that yeah as a rookie
it was a long year you go you know you
used to being done in November right and
I'm planning maybe 12 games you know we
from the preseason all the way to the
Super Bowls probably 24 games so I'm
exhausted
mmm Randall gay was starting in front of
me and he got like walking pneumonia
maybe two days before again no way it's
like I'm in third quarter he just tapped
out body shut down and they throw me in
and for three days straight I just see
Peyton Manning looking at me if licking
his chops changing the play every time
he listened I was good but man it was a
crazy crazy game we went into it knowing
I look we're going to steal the
possession so we were gonna do this
onside kick at some point in the game we
practiced it for a good two or three
weeks did that right out of half and got
that and in Tracy Porter got to pick six
late and it was it was Friday we
practiced that play maybe ten times now
hey Reggie Wayne is is in the slot and I
think it was Kali was it was the slot
receiver he's at the number one if he
motions down and running his final round
and he ran it Tracy Porter picks it off
see it goes to the house and then we
just found out you know our from Travis
Kelce when he was here on Tuesday they
practiced that 1948 Rose Bowl play that
shocker on fourth and one in the first
quarter
where they popped out some old-school
wild formation and he said they
practiced that for 11 weeks then 11
weeks I thought I goes you keep it in
your pocket until you need it
your coaches bolting up the collar well
I mean he said the reason why that they
practice it for so long didn't didn't
use it as coz Sammy Watkins couldn't
what'd he say spin he couldn't pivot he
couldn't rotate her knew this man said
he couldn't do the spin he kept on
stepping on himself yeah this is what he
said football's a funny game it is a
funny game and how long was Philly
special being practiced you know what I
mean
it couldn't be I never even saw it in
practice I think they might have ran at
one time out I might have missed it in
like a walk through no kidding but they
never really like practiced it that many
times so when that happened were you
like where did this come from
yeah I was surprised I didn't know
what's coming they did like the Patriots
yeah founders dropped is they ran the
same one actually it's a similar play
the Pacers ran eras in the same game and
they ran it against us a couple years
before right but no kidding so you know
yes that wasn't one that they were like
practicing every week like we're gonna
run this on somebody it just came out of
nowhere
I think they might have installed it
that week it's amazing I mean we just
named three of one of the some of the
more memorable plays in Super Bowl
history obviously you know the onside
kick you're the Philly special and then
the interception and I guess maybe this
1948 Rose Bowl play we'll be talking
about God fourth down I mean that's down
too and you know also in Philadelphia
what Andy Reid has meant there and what
he was not unfortunately able to
accomplish what did you make of this
Super Bowl what are your impressions of
what the Chiefs didn't of what the 49ers
could have done they were right there on
the doorstep yeah I think that I think
that she's really solidified themselves
as just you know they they're that team
to beat you know now just because you
had a lot of teams that were able to
jump on them especially like the last
three games for them hmm
teams jumped on them score points tried
to control the game but it's just it's
inevitable that my Holmes is going to
you know make something happen and
they're going to stretch at some point
in the game
you know similar to like what we saw in
a Golden State a couple years ago where
it's like you can be up on them but you
know at some point in the game they're
going to run and this will be really
impressive and so I think that's you
know what that Chiefs team is I thought
the 49ers when you look at how fast
they've turned that program over it's
been really impressive and what they've
done with that defense and the
leadership that they have on that that
team they're also you know a team that's
built to sustain and be successful for
years to come what do you Malcolm
Jenkins here on the Rich Eisen show and
then now the Eagles tons of coaching
changes tons of turnover on that
coaching staff are you surprised by that
no I mean some like we lost Cory
Underland to to Adi coordinator
perceives the defensive backs coach he's
not a d coordinator of the Detroit Lions
which was gonna happen at some point he
passed on of like a few years in a row
passing some dechlorinated jobs I think
it's gonna be it's gonna be a lot of
change this offseason for the whole
organization I just think we just add
that Junction point so it usually starts
with the coaches and we'll see what
happens little players and then you show
up in the spring you figure out who your
team is and then you you know you move
from there now you are you're on the
last year of your contract not one more
year look at one more year left what's
your future do you think I don't know I
mean you know I was I was really looking
forward to hopefully getting something
done or deal done during the season that
didn't happen and so now it's just kind
of as we approach you know the end of
the year and frayed to see all those
different things hopefully we can get
something done you know before then but
if not you know I'm looking to get a new
contract or figure out what my future is
so do you think like as you and I are
sitting here right now Malcolm Jenkins
that you will finish your career in
Philadelphia Lee hope so I'm at like
that's my home you know and I lived
there and I love that city I love that
organization and that team and
what you know I've really established
there in that city so hopefully I can be
there but I also understand you know
this is a business I've been in sure I
got to fill the accounting from the same
situation in New Orleans right you know
same thing love that city love the
people but you know at the end of the
day you gotta do what you got to do
right of course and then I'm you know I
started the interview saying that you're
from New Jersey Piscataway further up
north than but he must have family there
still I'm you know moving to Philly was
really for me like the turning point in
my career this and any really my life is
being able to get to that city what my
mind you know trajectory of my career
change being back closer to home close
to the family close and friends in a
larger market all of those things have
been great for me so yeah that is still
even if I end up somewhere else that'll
still be my own okay I'd like to take a
break and then on the other side of this
talk about the business of football
what's going on I know why you're out
here in Los Angeles right you're part of
the player rep so I'll meet them
together yeah talk a little bit about
your foundation the Malcolm Jenkins
foundation and Malcolm found Jenkins
foundation org and then I'm always
straight up with you I'm gonna keep you
talking run out the clock before we can
get to what I'm sure you want to talk
about and a college football season no
I'm just I'm just gonna I'm always gonna
shoot you straight this I just want to
keep talk I would Swan to keep talking
and tells us oh we're out of time gotta
go that's cool you really think that's
cool it's no need to beat a dead horse I
think it's good I'm kind of tired kind
of tired enough is born I wish you guys
would do something about your program I
came that came fast Malcolm Jenkins is
here on the Rich Eisen show at Malcolm
Jenkins on Twitter at Malcolm Jenkins 27
on Instagram we'll come back and find
out what the future holds for the NFL
collective bargaining agreement and then
and then so much more right here with
Malcolm Jenkins on the Rich Eisen show
don't go anywhere
another segment chatting here with
three-time pro-bowler and two-time Super
Bowl champion Malcolm Jenkins from the
Philadelphia Eagles who I'm I surprised
with a stat that you didn't even know
about yourself only got a beat Brady and
Manning and a super brand of Super Bowl
are you worried you played every
defensive snap for the fifth time in six
seasons
okay wear that are you aware that you've
never missed a game since signing with
the Eagles in 2014 okay are you aware
that this is the actual ten year
anniversary of your Super Bowl
championship with the Saints today today
yes oh my gosh all right so let's talk
about the here and now in the future you
were part of the NFL Players Association
I guess play a wrap meeting that is here
in Los Angeles yeah how do you think it
went I thought well I mean you know
whenever it comes down to the business
of football especially from the players
mm-hmm you know we've got to try to get
2,000 players and bodies kind of on the
same Accord and that takes a lot of you
know time on tires that takes a lot of
you know conversations for guys to be
able to represent their locker rooms
correctly to be able to take those
desires and bring them to the
negotiating table with League owners so
I think you know the more and more we
continue I had a dialogue we had an
another meeting last week we'll continue
to meet like as we we go throughout
throughout this process so obviously as
you point out there's I don't want to
say different agendas but obviously what
you might consider important another
player might not and vice versa like for
instance you're not gonna get in any
trouble that might need some sort of
player discipline but you might also
think that's important for the league
writ large in your player body what is
the most important issue for you Malcolm
I mean there's that there are a ton of
things I think the biggest thing is from
you know we look at the economics
there's obviously TV money that's that's
gonna come in ratings are up for the
league so there's an R
opportunity for all of us to make money
there there's this new gambling money
and trying to figure out you know how we
define that and what that industry takes
and and so all of those things you know
you want to figure out how we also you
know we want to strengthen our body so
it's not just the top guys that get
these max contracts but how do we how do
we strengthen you know that the everyday
player that only makes it three or four
years but push their bodies on the line
and keeps the lead kind of going
so there's priorities that we have as
players but that varies from different
different locker rooms you know some
guys care about working conditions and
in our offseason programs and training
camp when how many padded practices
things like that the quality of life so
you gotta weigh all of these different
things your your benefits package you
know what life is gonna be after the
game like I said what you're gonna be
doing during a game and economics and
you start the way you know what's more
important which not me in the back of my
career I'm very concerned about the the
economics of the business especially you
know further out I think we have an
opportunity as a league to continue to
grow but to make you know to give
ourselves as players a little bit more
equity in this game and really you know
address this as partners in the business
of football are you talking about a
revenue split is that what you're
referring to or what are you referring
for was I mean we've had we've had
different it's different ways to go
about it you can you can talk about the
revenue split but like right now and the
way it is just throwing money on the
table is not enough because we've seen
the top players get more money and it
squeezes and pinches kind of the middle
class of our league so it's not just
about generating more revenue but how do
we disperse that revenue through out our
locker rooms is a lot of the
conversation that we're having as
players and with with league management
Malcolm Jenkins here in the Rich Eisen
show do you think franchise tags are
here to stay go away what do you think
um you know that affects only a small
percentage but it is something that that
might affect eventually I'm not sure if
it'll if it's either here to stay or
whatever but I do think that for us as
players we want to limit as many
restrictions as possible it's
kind of opposite for the lead they want
to be able to control you know players I
think there's a fine line to some things
that are reasonable but you know yeah I
think some of our top guys you want them
in the market because they set the
market they you know it says here's the
marquee makes more and more money who
everyone who follows up may correct so
you don't want your best players to be
restricted and so there's gonna be to
some discussions of if not it probably
not eliminating but of how we can
manipulate and the bright shiny object
for at least us and the media is a 17
game schedule that's what everybody's
talking about how did what was the
conversation about that in the room yeah
I think the biggest thing is you know
with 17 games like what does that look
like and what does that mean on a
multiple you know things how would how
does that affect everybody financially
you know are you getting paid for
another for another game what does that
do to your body are there you know
effects on your health you know playing
a whole nother game does that extend the
season does that reduce your workload
and offseason but what is it entail what
are you being told it would entail right
now everything is very very broad and in
vague you know we haven't really gotten
into the weeds of what that actually
looks like like an extra five week and
stuff like that I mean there's a lot of
everything right now is just ideas of
how we could make that work and I think
we'll be trying to figure out if that
even makes sense for for players I don't
think anybody wants to play another game
but I think obviously there's an
opportunity to make more money
you know but like I said it's we have to
decide as players is that worth it and
it's not just about the money it's about
our longevity as players and and
obviously where that money goes is
everybody gonna see a bit of this new
money or is it gonna stay at the top of
the league so all of those things are a
very you know vague right now I'm broad
but we're continuing to kind of dissect
them and figure out what our locker
rooms want so we can properly represent
that at the negotiating table and are
there guys in the room saying absolutely
not no 17 games let's just move on table
it finish it I think there's a there's a
wide spectrum of opinions
you know some guys don't and most of the
veterans don't want to play another game
sure because we know what the effects
you know 16-game season is on the body
already um but I think they're the
majority of guys are are open if it's
worth it you know if what comes with it
is worth it and then we can negotiate if
not then we won't but I think it's too
early for us to really even gauge where
we are alright and then the last one for
your on this subject is the conversation
is hey the idea is to get it done before
the new league year begins in the middle
of next month March 18th that way we
know there's labor peace certainly that
might help with television contract
negotiations that are there that
everybody knows you get in right now and
you pay the premium price you get labor
peace for all this time yeah what are
the odds of that happening do you think
the I can't give I know players are now
moving on that timeline I think we we
have to make sure we get this right and
we don't want to feel like we're under
under the gun we understand you know the
urgency and and and all the other things
you just laid out but that's not gonna
push us into you know accepting to do or
taking to do I think we're still having
meetings we're talking you know
constantly through our locker rooms into
each other I think you know it's a
possibility but it's not something that
we are pushing to be on that timeline
Malcolm Jenkins here in the Rich Eisen
show let's talk in the final few minutes
we have here about what's going on with
you what is listen up media that you are
yeah so so launching last year I started
a production company called listen up
media with the intentions of just really
owning my own storytelling being able to
put out you know films with his
documentaries or series or feature films
or whatever just that you know on a
narrative and in change take that
narrative back for people of color and
marginalized you know communities and be
able to like own that that storytelling
and so the first project I'm on
it's called black boys it's directed by
Sonia Loman
that'll be in the Toronto Film Festival
was that next week so that's that was a
project I really enjoyed working on
allowed to like help edit it's about
kind of the spectrum of humanity of
black boys and how even as early as you
know grade school that humanity is being
tested and tried there's another film
called first day back and that's about
the first day of a school returning
after there's been a school shooting in
like what that's like in Philadelphia to
be in a school where you have to go
through metal detectors you have to you
know almost be imprisoned in your own
school and what effect that has on the
kids that are there how is the most
impossible learning environment but this
is really a reality for a lot of schools
you know around the country an answer
that that's a scripted film that also be
at a Toronto black Film Fest so I was
really looking forward to you know
learning in really owning those
narratives and then there's the Malcolm
Jenkins foundation org I've been told is
this a suit that you're wearing
something from your own oh yeah
so I belong here yeah for about two and
a half years now I've had d'marie
seville's is my clothing company we have
a brick-and-mortar in Philadelphia so we
do men's and women's suiting so I've
been you know I pretty much designed all
the things that I wear that's that's
another passion projects ed you've got a
lot of those men and then you're
entering your twelfth season in the NFS
dozen years a dozen years and then the
Malcolm Jenkins foundation I've got
about a minute left and I'm not I I'm
not really running out the clock I'm not
talking about Michigan Ohio State but I
do I do want to say just again your
foundation is remarkable and Washington
have done you know being in Walter
Payton Man of the Year nominee is a
terrific terrific tremendous thing to be
yeah and so what you've done is is
amazing thank you it really is well we
are out of time I mean Chris tell them
how the radio clock works I mean it's
just we have about 30
seconds Malcolm sorry about that so we
can talk about how state missing Thank
You coach man what what are y'all doing
with our coats we're gonna have him be
on the sidelines next year
Malcolm y'all are standing by well I'm
serious we have literally run out of
time thanks for thanks for coming on
Malcolm oh is he
Malcolm Jenkins on Twitter here on the
Rich Eisen show don't go for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app